[Music]
all right so I talked to the contestants
earlier today and they are going through
all sorts of emotions right now it's the
finale night they're anxious they're
excited
what do you backstage say to them when I
get to meet them before they go out on
stage I always I love to find out what
they're about and kind of pull out
what's kind of going on underneath the
surface basically I'm telling them you
know what whatever you're doing right
now God is with you
so whatever path you're supposed to walk
you're supposed to walk that path that's
why I always say walk your path with
pride cuz I didn't know I was gonna join
a group called the Black Eyed Peas but
it's one of the best things I've ever
done so you never know which way your
path is gonna take you so embrace it
love it you're here for a reason
Fergie gearing up for the season 2
finale of the force only thing that
could it beat you walked out on the
stage and after that now that the four
is wrapping up what do you have planned
are you going on vacations are you
looking to date are you looking to just
have some more movie time or music I'll
tell you right now I'm play dating with
other Barrett's that's what I'm doing
and just finishing the four I'm all
about this we're gonna have our big
party to watch the final episode and I'm
super excited about that and yeah just
being my kid being home and growing on
planted yep Fergie's number one focus is
on son Axl your son is turning five at
the end of August do you are you pulling
out all the stops or what are you doing
this year dad is gonna have the birthday
party at his house last year was a
pirate party yes this year were thinking
superhero party because every single
week he wants to be a different
superhero okay so who is he 11 right now
right now he's loving - and I got
Elastigirl pajamas so I don't know where
the cat suit around the house yeah I
kind of got sick of wearing the cat
suits of everything because who wants to
work at sit all the time so this is the
trip parents you get the pajamas of the
superhero so they think you're dressing
up
you are but your comfy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]